okay so now let's talk about inflation
because even though we are fighting back
they are going to keep coming they are
an unstoppable rebel force but we are
going to stop them they think they're
unstoppable but they are not that's the
secret
uh here's gensake this is monday a
warning of the high inflation situation
so because of the actions we've taken to
address uh putin the putin price hike we
are in a better place than we were last
month um but we expect march cpa cpi
headline inflation to be extraordinarily
elevated due to putin's price hike and
we expect a large difference between
core and headline inflation reflecting
the global disruptions in energy and
food markets so chlorine inflation
doesn't include energy and food prices
uh headline inflation does
putin's price like putin's price act
putin's price hike it has nothing to do
with them
printing all this money it has nothing
to do with them giving out all this
money it has nothing to do with any of
the ridiculous
policies that they have instituted it's
putin's price hike it's almost as if
these people have nothing to do with
anything happening right now it's quite
extraordinary they keep putting on their
fancy outfits and they keep giving
speeches and they stand at lecterns and
they do all of this stuff but they don't
have anything to do with anything going
on it's just this guy in russia who can
do whatever he wants to us at any point
quite extraordinary wouldn't you say
but we've got actual numbers
from nbc today the rising cost of
everyday life in this country new
numbers confirming what we already know
inflation is skyrocketing reaching a 41
year high we're getting a sense of
exactly how much it is costing the
average american family nbc's tom
costello on the story again for us tom
good morning
yeah we are seeing higher prices for
everything for food for housing for used
cars but the biggest driver of this last
month
energy fuel gas prices now the bite
administration is adding more ethanol
into the summer blend hoping that that
will in fact help drive down gas prices
the bottom line though experts say the
impact may be minimal
many americans have known it for a long
time but now it is official inflation is
skyrocketing hitting 8.5 percent last
month the highest since 1981. a big
driver gas prices which a new government
forecast predicts will reach an
eight-year high this summer while right
now prices are down 24 cents from their
highs in march the national average is
still four dollars eight cents a gallon
up a dollar 22 cents from a year ago now
the biden administration is announcing a
temporary summertime waiver to allow for
the sale of e-15 a blend of gas with 15
percent ethanol even if it's an extra
buck or two in the pockets they fill up
will make a difference in people's lives
but adding more ethanol may have a
limited impact since only one and a half
percent of gas stations nationwide
actually carry e15 it's not just energy
prices that are fueling inflation food
is up 8.8 year over year the biggest
annual increase in 41 years you
literally cannot make this [ __ ] up their
their solution is to put more ethanol
in the gas which is not good for the
cars that's why the ethanol is not there
in the first place and only 1.5
of the gas stations allow for this right
okay do you realize how insane these
people are but it has nothing to do with
them because there is a scary man in
russia and he rides a horse without a
shirt
and he must be stopped at all costs it
is complete and utter nonsense it is a
total shell game they do all of the
stuff that has ransacked and wrecked the
economy this was not happening under
scary orange man and then they blame
shirtless horse-riding russian guy get
rid of your vodka if you're a true
american
but they also try to scare the hell out
of you the entire time because if they
didn't do the stuff that they're doing
you'd be starving
take responsibility for his decisions
like some say the american rescue plan
boosted demand uh when it didn't need to
larry summers was one of those well the
alternative would have been uh that we
would have gone into a massive economic
downward spiral and many americans would
have not had enough food to put on the
table so we chose the other path
can you believe it guys if they hadn't
done all this good stuff that they've
been doing printing money out of nowhere
and all of the great things that this
administration is doing you wouldn't
have food on the table you'd be
absolutely starving sure your food is
extremely expensive and your gas is
extremely expensive and there's not as
much stuff on the shelves and everything
is taking forever to get delivered
actually we're trying to just paint our
guest bedroom white we're going to turn
a guest bedroom into the baby's room we
just want to literally paint it white
and the contractor came yesterday and he
said that paint white paint is four
times as expensive as it was last year
but thank you sake